does NATO marks its 7 70th anniversary
this week the Alliance has stated that
one of its main challenges is the threat
from a more assertive Russia at a
meeting in Washington NATO members
approved measures to counter Russia in
the Black Sea region including increased
naval cooperation with Georgia and
Ukraine a correspondent Alexandra
phenomen spoke about future NATO
missions for the director of policy
planning of the US State Department
Chiron Skinner how much of the threat is
Russia still posing to NATO members yes
we would of course to cooperate with
Russia but the discussions that we've
had with NATO partners in the past
couple of days underscore the fact that
Russia's behavior of annexing Crimea and
violating the territorial and political
sovereignty of its neighbors and we go
back to Georgia in 2008 is still
important for all of us but there are
other factors as well the way that
Russia seeks to undermine in the gray
zone and through hybrid conflict below
the level of armed warfare is something
that the NATO partners have discussed in
the last couple of days so I think there
is a common understanding that the
sanctions that the US has supported with
NATO against Russia in Ukraine are
significant and and must continue I
think there's really been little
daylight about our understanding of the
nature of the threats that NATO faces
not just from Russia but from around the
globe and that's really been the core of
what we've talked about it today and
today and in the past couple of days
I never topic that continues to occupy
the Alliance's burden-sharing and
president Trump's constant criticism has
rattled the European allies it's the US
administration now happy with increasing
the defense spending among NATO members
that's what the president says and in
fact he said so in his meeting with the
NATO secretary-general and then
importantly the NATO secretary-general
himself in the first-ever
presence before the US Congress talked
about this very fact in his speech the
at NATO's increased defense spending
under the kind of pressure from the US
president has been a force for good in
the NATO alliance
I think it's led to a deeper
understanding of the threat we face it's
not just about money but it's about
being prepared for threats and it's
being being prepared in a way that tells
all potential challengers that we they
shouldn't mess with NATO Germany has
been repeatedly singled out in this
context by the US president at the same
time opinion polls showed that the vast
majority of Germans have little trust in
us in the u.s. president and in the US
administration the new opinion how deep
is the damage to the us-german relations
that's a hard one for me because I'm
such a great friend of Germany I've been
there many times and I understand our
deep historic ties and I think they will
endure you have to remember that NATO
and the Western alliance the g7 over the
decades if you look back there have been
periods of friction periods of
disagreement but the Alliance has
endured and that's important perhaps
we're in one of those patches but I
think the Americans and Germans at least
from the American diplomatic perspective
Germany's been a core ally on so many
fronts you've stood alongside us in the
21st century in numerous conflicts and I
think you know we're mature family of
Western nations committed to similar
values this is what happens in a mature
family that has commitment to similar
values we don't always agree on the
pathway to the outcomes that we want but
I think we're United and outcomes were
United in values and what the president
has tried to do with this idea of
America first is also say let's make
sure that our interest prevail and then
try to find common ground there even
when there are some divergence so I
think the us-german relationship is one
that will endure thank you very much
you and that was Chiron Skinner of the
US State Department speaking to DWS
Alexandra from phenomena now as NATO
marks at 70th anniversary an
overwhelming majority of Germans think
it's as vital as ever a nationwide poll
asked whether NATO is important in order
to secure peace in Europe 82% that's
four out of five said they agree only 15
percent of respondents disagree so
strong backing for NATO here in Germany
and for some analysis I'm joined by DW
political correspondent Kate Brady Kate
it appears the Alliance is as relevant
as ever on both sides of the Atlantic it
certainly is very relevant and something
that's been occupying politicians and
the public here in Germany quite
extensively for the past few months now
and if you look at those stats that we
saw there and take them at face value
you'd think that you know there can't be
much more of a loyal NATO member than
Germany but actually it has a very
German II has a very interesting
relationship with NATO of course there's
the issue over over the spending its
military spending but Germans do still
have quite a close relationship to NATO
there's a sense of almost historical
debt especially due to the role that
NATO played during the Cold War but at
the same time German history also plays
an important role in Germany's
continuing reluctance to really
participate in frontline military
operations of course that has changed
particularly in the last couple of
decades whether it being involved in in
the Balkans and in Afghanistan for
example but there still is very much
this reluctance both from politicians
and from the public to be actively
involved in military combat all right
now all 29 NATO allies have committed to
spending 2% of GDP on their military and
to reach that goal Germany would have to
increase its military budget
significantly now when pollsters asked
Germans whether the country's military
budget should be increased to 2% of GDP
only 43% answered I agree
but a majority of people in Germany 53
percent is opposed
this increase in military spending so
Kate why are so many Germans so
reluctant to open their their pockets to
essentially spending money on their own
defense when in fact they say NATO's so
important well this is becoming a huge
bugbear and as we heard they're just in
the interview there we're here in
particularly vocal opposition and
demands from from their US and Germany
last year spends 1.2 3% of its GDP on
defense and that now the the current
budget at least plans to increase that
to 1.5 percent by 2024 but this 2
percent hurdle or target so say of GDP
spending on on defense is still a long
way away and there's actually an open
end target there in Germany but they
still as I mentioned has very much to do
with the reluctance in Germany to
participate in front-line military
operations and the SPD which was is the
minor is a junior partner in the
governing coalition right now they have
really put the brakes on defense
spending and instead they're calling for
more money to be invested into actual
military capabilities but that in itself
is a really big challenge for Germany
there's been really damning reports over
the last few months about the state of
the Bundeswehr of the German military
with lack of recruits lack of equipment
so that itself is very difficult and the
idea of even getting Germans to become
members of the military as well is a
whole different challenge as a debate
ongoing right now about whether the
Bundeswehr should be going into schools
to even promote the fact that people can
get a career there so this certainly
isn't a subject that is going to be off
the agenda anytime soon all right
the W's political correspondent Kay
Brady thank you so much to Libya now
where forces loyal to a powerful militia
leader have reached the outskirts of
Tripoli the seat of the country's
un-backed government the offensive
launched by General